S
RIGHT NOW BUT THERE IS A LOT
GOING ON AND IT'S REALLY SAD AND
PARENTS ARE JUST ABOUT OVER IT.
CLAY TRAVIS HAS PROVEN THAT NT
IS ONE OF THE PARENTS WHO SPOKE
OUT TO THE SCHOOL BOARD TO THEIR
FACES.
HE IS A BUSY MAN, COMPOSED OF
"THE CLAY TRAVIS AND BUCK SEXTON
SHOW."
HE IS ALSO FOUNDER OF THE ONLY
WEBSITE COVERING SPORTS AND
POLITICS THAT YOU WOULD WANT TO
READ.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
I LOVE THE CLIP, I KNOW IT WAS A
MUCH LONGER SPEECH THAT YOU MADE
AND GOD BLESS YOU FOR DOING IT
AND IT WAS ENTIRELY FACT-BASED.
THE REACTION FROM THE OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM REALLY STRUCK
ME.
WHAT IS YOUR SENSE OF WHERE
PARENTS ARE RIGHT NOW WITH
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN SCHOOLS?
>> FIRST, TUCKER, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME.
SECOND, WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF
WHAT I THINK IS A GRASSROOTS
MOBILIZING PARENT MOVEMENT TO
TAKE BACK THIS COUNTRY.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE
ARE FRUSTRATED BECAUSE THE
REACTION I SAW DEMONSTRATED THAT
AND WHERE WE ARE IN
WILLIAMSON COUNTY, I THINK THERE
ARE COUNTLESS PEOPLE ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY WHO FEEL THE SAME
WAY THAT WE DO, THAT WE HAVE TO
GO RIGHT TO THE ROOT.
YOU'VE GOT A TELEVISION SHOW,
I'VE GOT A RADIO SHOW, WE MAKE
GOOD LIVINGS DOING OUR JOBS BUT
THE MOST IMPORTANT JOB WE HAVE
IS BEING A PARENT.
BEING A MOM, BEING A DAD.
I THINK WHAT HAPPENED DURING
COVID'S MANY PARENTS BECAME
AWARE OF WHAT THEIR KIDS WERE
BEING TAUGHT.
I'M A PUBLIC-SCHOOL KID.
I WENT TO NASHVILLE CITY PUBLIC
SCHOOL, K-12, MY KIDS, TWO OF
THEM ARE IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS RIGHT
NOW.
I WANT FOR THEM TO FIT IN IN THE
SOCIETY AND MAKE THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE.
BUT IT HAS TO BE A FACT-BASED
REALITY AND RIGHT NOW, IT ISN'T
AND I'M EXCITED ABOUT HOW MANY
PARENTS ARE NOW RISING UP.
OVER 1,000 PEOPLE SHOWED UP AT
THAT SCHOOL BOARD MEETING
OUTSIDE OF NASHVILLE TOOK ABOUT
THE DECISIONS BEING MADE BY THE
BOARD.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT IS THE
ONLY WAY.
YOU'VE BEEN ENGAGED IN THIS AS
OTHER PEOPLE HAVE OVER THE LAST
YEAR, TRYING TO REASON WITH THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF THE SCHOOLS,
FROM THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
THE TEACHERS UNION SCHOOL BOARDS
TO THE TEACHERS AND SAY THIS IS
POISON.
YOU CANNOT CREATE TOOTSIES IN
AMERICA, AND THEY JUST WON'T
LISTEN.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANOTHER
OPTION THAN FOR PARENTS TO JUST
SAY "NO MORE."
BECAUSE THAT IS THE OPTION,
TUCKER.
I ENCOURAGE EVERYONE OUT THERE.
I'M SAYING THIS IS A MOM-LED
REVOLUTION BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK
AT THE CROWDS, MOMS HAVE HAD A
LOT PUT ON THEM FOR THE LAST 18
MONTHS.
THEY HAD TO BEAR THE BRUNT OF
CHILD CARE, WHEN WE HAD 15 DAYS
TO STOP THE SPREAD AND THEY ARE
JUST FED UP WITH IT AND THEY ARE
LEADING THE CHARGE AND THAT IS
WHAT I ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO
DO.
SPEAK OUT, GO TO THE GRASSROOTS,
CONFRONT YOUR SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS, DEMAND THE USE
FACT-BASED ANALYSIS AND WE WILL
WIN.
I'M TELLING YOU, WE ARE GOING TO
WIN, I SEE IT.
IT'S GOING TO GROW AND SPREAD
AND BECOME BIGGER THAN IT
ALREADY IS.
THE ANTI-MASS, ANTI-CRT VERY
WELL MAY BE THE NEXT TEA PARTY.
THAT IS THE FIRST HELPFUL THING
I